alright here we are again doing another
movie retrospective yeah is when we grew
up with yeah going back to the 1970s for
this one Alice sweet Alice yeah yeah if
you grew up during the 80s this one was
on HBO and Cinemax a lot it was yeah
it's good to [ __ ] out of you when you
were a kid it's super creepy it's creepy
and movies of this era were realistic
yeah there's like there's definitely
like kind of like a grungy yeah kind of
especially did this one it's like kind
of like a yeah they didn't really rely
on special effects or anything and so
everything that they showed you
happening is something that could happen
cuz it did the show showed it happening
on-screen yeah I thought my CGI or an
even really use a whole lot of
special-effects makeup
really they had blood but yeah people
get knifed yeah and and it was the story
and just the tenor and the tone of these
movies were disturbing even back then
yeah there's just something about it
like I said that I don't think they can
ever really replicate all that well like
some have tried to replicate it more
recently and stuff but I feel like Alice
sweet Alice I feel like it's a little
bit underappreciated um for 70s horror
maybe not but it does really seem like a
lot of people maybe haven't seen it
haven't seen it in a long time one of
the things we noticed is of course it's
made in the seventies like we said about
76 70 76706 we realized it was a period
piece I never realized that I was
watching a calendar said 96 it's
supposed to be set in 1961 all the cars
of course was 60s in it it's happening
in like an italian-american community
you know really super Catholic yeah and
at the time I kind of thought it was an
Italian movie but yeah it's not it's not
yeah I'll get into that a little it's a
fake Italian movie yeah it's a fake jala
movie yeah but it's good that's exactly
what it is yeah I had a little
what's-her-name in it little what's her
name you know I'm talking about yeah
Brooke Shields the one that Jackson was
all into she's probably about 12 in it I
know I think she's young girl even this
is actually her first movie I think she
was only nine her times okay we she's
cute as a bug and then there's another
girl who's playing her sister I thought
it was a twin sister but I guess it's
older so she's older and she's
she's supposed to be 12 yeah yeah I
forgot what her name was Shepard is that
yeah Paul Shepherd she was she's in
another movie called liquid which is
kind of like a new romantic goth movie
that was from 82 I'm eighty tits on
shudder right now Chucky a super super
super [ __ ] weird had all kind of
weird gender-bending and necrophilia and
aliens coming over heroin a lien
I think that's what I don't really know
what it was about yeah that one that
movie is Mel yeah that movie is what
happens when you take all your goth
friends together in the club you make a
movie that's what that was about
and you take all the drugs yeah yeah
pretty much and you got people playing
two parts of male part and a female part
that's fun that part was pretty cool I
got I was challenged any asses that's
not a guy that's a girl cuz no that's a
guy that is a girl and turned out that
girl was playing both the male role and
the female yeah cuz like I said everyone
looked very androgynous yes but anyway
the girl please Alice isn't also in that
movie she's probably about I don't know
19 or 20 no she was actually nineteen in
this movie okay she's a little woman she
is a tiny she made me for ten for Allah
that's why she played yes she did in
this she could play a child she kind of
passes and she has that baby face yeah
like a little round [ __ ] she's cute
she's cute yeah
but then in the other ones you get she
was in her 20s and she was playing this
[ __ ] crazy ass like necrophiliac
chick
I recommend that movie to that one was
[ __ ] fun if you're like in this into
really weird like any cinema it's on
shudder right now that's you can
probably get in other places too but
yeah it's like super super you got to be
patient with that movie because it just
tells the story it wants to tell you
yeah I can't make that something it
isn't and like I said it doesn't really
have much of a plot or narrative right
the aliens trying to steal the heroin
out of people's veins I guess yeah I
think that's I think that's what was but
yeah so Alice sweet Alice um was
actually the guy that directed it was
named Alfred's soul now prior to doing
this movie he only had one film credit
and it was a porno it was called deep
sleep and it came out in 1972 now he got
in a lot of legal hot water
filming the
poor no I tried to figure out like what
exactly was the problem like he filmed
it in Paterson New Jersey just like
Alice sweet Alice was also filmed there
that was his hometown that was where he
grew up so he filmed this porno there
and then he got brought up on obscenity
charges yeah because I guess like
because I looked at the charges and it
was like against him and like some of
the actors the film for fornication well
which is unmarried people having sex
which was apparently illegal back then
yeah well there's a bunch of weird
County laws and that's it might have
been that they could come at you with
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] probably what
happened was is that he was in an area
where the county and local authorities
didn't want a pornographic film being
that's what I think after they came out
of all kinds of weird-ass [ __ ] you know
what I think in order to drive him out
and also nothing is is that for the
younger audiences
you know porn in the 70s was not the
port of today porn of the 70s lot of it
was actually full-length production
films they were moved oh yeah because
they played at theaters yeah they play
man theater they had whole stories and
you know I mean they actually acted like
who want that yeah it wasn't efficient
eighties VHS killed that off like if he
wants to sit turn well they had big
Hollywood openings and they were
supposed to be competing with Hollywood
and they there was gone on they were
trying to be respectful
a respectable yeah like they were real
movies well it kind of worked they were
in the late seventies like it kind of
went mainstream for yeah particularly if
like marilyn Chambers yeah other guys
got involved with porno they're real and
that's not what people want they just
want the sex they don't want the stories
so they were just selling VHS a bunch of
little scenes yeah and that's and that's
so the old porn what else they were
right there like never writes it through
a 90-minute yeah that dominated the
market who them like talking to each
other and stuff slickly the [ __ ] wants
to see it yeah watch movie if we want to
go with theater full of dudes sucking in
it tugging it to that was just weird
monkey ass for ya VHS [ __ ] killed all
that and I'm glad that it killed all
that that was a you know that's nasty it
is pretty nuts yeah but yeah so anyway
um yeah so so there was like some
legally
she was like he was not allowed to make
another movie like in Paterson New
Jersey at ursin New Jersey for like two
years he didn't do any prison time or
anything like that even if you did like
even with charges of like fornication I
think it was like only a $50 fine or
something like that so wasn't a good
deal but they were just like being a
pain in the ass just for the sake of
being a pain in the ass because they
didn't like the idea of somebody filming
a porno there now the idea for doing
this legit movie came after he saw the
awesome and actually one of my favorite
70s horror movies the awesome movie
don't look now directed by Nicolas Roy
which we actually did a review of
earlier on the show now he saw that
movie which came out in 1973 and he
wanted to do something similar to it and
there are very obvious homage is to that
movie and this one like the killer wears
a raincoat you know and don't look now
it was red in this one it's yellow you
know and how the plot goes down and I am
gonna spoil this so if you owe more so
if you haven't seen it um you can
actually watch it for free on to be Oh
YouTube yeah but I'm just saying if you
want it because the YouTube one is like
the shitty VHS transfer okay um so if
you want to see it better and you can
see it for nothing you just go on to BTB
they have it I just checked earlier
today and they watched we watch the
Youtube version it's like that yeah
yeah it looks fine and apparently either
late last year early this year arrow
video released like a deluxe blu-ray of
it that they it's all been restored this
audience been restored like there's like
a [ __ ] ton of like extras on it and
everything I've seen of it I haven't
seen the blu-ray transfer but everybody
that I've seen review it is that it's
beautiful
hmm cuz this is a nice-looking movie but
as I said you can really see the
influence of Don't Look Now
even though don't look now I was more
like a psychological horror I would call
this one more a slasher but classier
than that term implies you know anything
it is a slasher and that's a
psychological thriller slash murder
mystery yeah because it does have like a
killer in you know an outfit and a mask
like going around killing multiple
people and you don't know who it is and
like you said this is very much like a
jell-o movie interestingly they're
different
so is that this one makes sense and a
lot of Jia Liu B's don't make sense
they don't yeah it's more about style
over substance yes one actually has a
story that makes sense I mean yeah but I
mean it's it is like as that style it's
a similar vibe yeah and the interesting
thing about it though is that the
director of this movie said that he had
never seen a geology brew where he made
this and then like he was or at least he
said he'd never seen any Dario Argento
or anything like that but he said oh I
didn't really see any but the fact that
he based it off of Hitchcock and based
it off of yeah that don't look now
that's what they were doing those were
you know Hitchcock was obviously a big
influence on giallo films and don't look
now is also influenced by j.lo films so
if you're gonna do something in that
line yeah yeah and there's another thing
about this movies in a weird way it also
kind of reminds me of a movie called the
other it is kind of like that has a if
you haven't seen that one that's a good
witness we did a review on the dinners
on that one check the other out this
also it gives me a little bit of a black
Christmas vibe also a little bit of
black Christmas in there too but the
whole setup of this movie is that Brooke
Shields is she's supposed to be 9 or 10
in the movie and at the beginning she's
gonna go through her first communion now
she has an older sister named Alice
who's played by Paula Shepard who as I
said she turned 19 while they were
filming this movie but she pulls I I
never would have guessed that she was
actually about 12 this she was that and
she's supposed to be 12 in the movie so
clearly there's like a really like um
toxic like family dynamic like you can
tell that the older sister is well the
younger sister played by Brooke Shields
whose name is Karen she is obviously the
favored sister she's super sweet and
like everybody loves her and the older
sister is a little kind of cranky and
she's very very jealous of her younger
sister now there's there's um some [ __ ]
to because the you know Brooke Shields
is getting her first communion but Alice
didn't get communion yeah because her
parents were divorced I'll be on spoiler
territory now well I said before it's
like from here on out just like it's
probably you want to see it go ahead
check don't you go to 2b and watch it
it's it's on there for free you don't
because the movies are mine [ __ ] it is
you're thinking something's happening
you're going damn but then you find out
that damn it
you had it all wrong all along you know
but I like that they did ambiguous too
because here's what happens now
interestingly when they first started
marketing this movie and like I said
they he wanted to call it communion that
was the original title of the movie but
when it was picked up by the US
distributors they so we can't call it
that because we don't want people
thinking it's a Christian movie cuz you
know that we'd like to I guess that's
too nice or whatever so they gave it the
name Alice sweet Alice I've also seen it
and then after Brooke Shields got super
famous like after a pretty baby came out
in 1978 then they rereleased this movie
like on recut a little bit in 1981 and
called it holy terror now interestingly
even though Brooke Shields was Oliver
and she's on the poster and everything
like that she is in this for maybe five
minutes yeah she gets killed like almost
immediately in this movie yeah I was
surprised like she got killed and I was
like women they killed off Brooke
Shields yeah well she wasn't a star but
a star back then you know it's like and
it's only later that they were like oh
it's Brooke Shields first movie even
though like she's literally and it may
even not maybe not even fun yeah and
she's uh she's like cute as a bug in it
she really is she's normal yeah and her
eyebrows weren't totally out of control
like more famous for her eyebrows you
could see why she became a star yeah you
see when you saw her in this movie at
that age she's not easy to forget yeah
but what I don't understand is why
didn't Shepard become a star because it
was badass too she well this is what
Hamburg because I looked her up I was
curious about that as well cuz I was
like cuz when we were watching liquid
sky the other day I'm like hey that's
the girl from Alice sweet Alice I
recognized her immediately cuz she
didn't really look that she's cute cute
as hell and yeah a good actress she's
like and I looked her up afterward after
she did lifts liquid skies she retired
she didn't want to act anymore so [ __ ]
she just went and like got married and
became a mom okay so which is weird
because like she always plays these well
you know did you maybe she was in
she played like these like kind of evil
yeah badass kind of characters and they
she was like no I just wanted to go be a
mom so she retired she just didn't want
to act anymore that's why well that's
good though you know it was her choice
it wasn't yeah it wasn't like she got
blackballed you know or any other reason
yeah she just didn't want to do it she
in my opinion you know she can do what
she wants to do but I would like to have
seen her in some other movies when the
80s rolled around there would have been
some badass roles she could have been oh
yeah she totally steals this movie yeah
I have to say but yeah so the so Brooke
Shields character Karen she's having her
first communion and her older sister is
very jealous about it she's jealous of
all this attention that her sister is
getting that she didn't get her parents
are divorced and her mom is clearly like
favoring the younger sister she talks to
the older one kind of like she's a dog
it's kind of upsetting but um so at the
first communion Karen gets dragged into
the back strangled put into the little
bench thing like the transept or
whatever they call that and then set on
fire yeah and in the middle of the
communion yeah and you're convinced that
the sister did it that Alice did well
because very clearly looks like because
here's the thing as soon as you know you
see the body and you see like the killer
with the yellow raincoat and the mask
and everything and then smoke starts
coming out of the bench or whatever and
then Alice comes in wearing a veil that
is presumably her sister's yeah and you
know crouches down at the thing like
trying to get communion and they won't
give it to her yeah so everyone starts
to think that she did it and the movie
wants to make you think that he is
guilty you go through this whole movie
pretty much thinking that alice is
knocking these people off and all of a
sudden you find that even including her
dad and then by the time the dad almost
gets knocked off they tell you that it's
not her it turned out you were actually
putting this on an innocent girl the
whole time yeah I was oh oh there was an
older woman who was impersonating this
girl yeah
dressed up in a costume you know it
looked like some alison wear but it was
no it wasn't yeah because those yellow
raincoats were actually like from the
church or from like that
Catholic school or whatever it was so
like a lot of kids had those um but yeah
the Halloween mask because you see Alice
wearing it early like in an early scene
like she wears it and she steals her
sister's doll and like scares are in a
warehouse and then there's all this kind
of inappropriate seventies [ __ ] like the
cops [ __ ] talking about [ __ ]
Alice's titties yeah though she's 12
Mosby 12 and they're talking about it -
it's [ __ ] then there's like clicking
the pervy ass landlord who yeah the
[ __ ] fat Anton LaVey yep they're
trying to put in trying to put the moves
on this little girl trying to molest her
and [ __ ] she kills his cat and revenge I
mean there's all kinds of [ __ ] badass
[ __ ] that would only happen in a 70s
flick yes the whole thing you know this
is disturbing [ __ ] anticipate a 70s was
even more politically incorrect than the
80s were and sometimes you thought the
80s were the 70s were into some [ __ ]
pervy ass [ __ ] yeah they would directly
address that [ __ ] I mean honestly and
and it's weird because just today I
watched the William freakin movie
cruising from 1980 which had without
very young Al Pacino you know going
undercover like in the leather bar like
the gay scene and then at like trying to
catch the serial killer and I was like I
was amazed at what they put in a movie
in 1980 I was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
early 80s they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
they were just about anything in there
so like a subversive then it would have
been it was cool so they were yeah in
there so like I said I mean this whole
movie the first five minutes she's a
nine-year-old girl gets strangled and
set on fire
yeah um then you think through the whole
thing that a twelve-year-old girl is the
one doing the killing and like you said
the interesting thing about it is that
Alice's character I like that they
portray her I mean obviously they
portray her as like a brat and she's
like always you know up to like sketchy
[ __ ] but they're almost kind of implying
yes she wasn't the murderer but but she
was sketchy
she was sketchy and she might become a
murderer like because the last scene of
it kind of suggests so it's almost kind
of like it's an
like kind of like what we were talking
about like on our show about Edie Kemper
where it's like a feedback loop right
because she feels neglected by her
family and because they they think even
though they don't say it to her face
they think that she killed her sister
and that she killed these other people
like she stabbed her aunts and stuff
like that so because they think that
that makes her act out even more because
she thinks that they don't love her and
they don't trust her they don't believe
her and so in some ways the movie kind
of hints yeah that this feedback loop is
going to make her go in that direction
because if she has that proclivity I'm
ready yeah because they ain't they end
off the end off the movie with a scene
where of course you know that means
she's absolved and their [ __ ] take
they're taking the guilty party into
custody was she killed
yeah she was killed once she who the
crazy has woman what she killed him just
captured I don't remember if they killed
her and I think maybe they just captured
her yeah um but then the camera pans
over to Alice at the very end and she's
kind of like picking up the mantle she's
got a me he's got the knife of the
killer and the mask and she's trying to
[ __ ] hide it all in her purse like
she's gonna take up the damn murder
spree her sight you know because you
know oh and treats her really there was
all the bad blood the day had blamed her
the whole you know that they'd believed
that she was doing all these murders
like I said everyone blamed her and it's
like and then like I said there's this
whole thing where she does do horrible
[ __ ] she kills the landlord's cat um you
know she leaves like a jar of
cockroaches on a float although I don't
care about that because that guy was
like he was kind of yeah he was like
very bravely trying he's trying to he
was trying to molest her interestingly
that guy that played that character this
was one of only three movies he was in
he was also in blood sucking freaks and
he was in one other one
he was quite cool it's interestingly the
director of this found him because one
of his things he was actually a bouncer
at a gay bar around there but one of his
side gigs was he would hang out in a
cemetery dressed as a priest and he
would take money from people to like
absolve them of various things he was
only a priest
okay so he was like this fan of reason
yeah he was like this local care said
the director like knew of him and
yeah we have to put you look like an
answer on the baseball he's got the
[ __ ] same way to lose fat yeah and he
had like he had like pants like you
really feel like you need a shower and
he can't really act but he's an
effective character in the movie it is
full of like weird characters like cuz
like the woman that plays the aunt aunt
Annie yeah um when she comes like after
Brooke Shields character gets murdered
like you know the aunt comes there to
help out the kids mom and her and Alice
hate each other so you know when the
aunt gets stabbed like she lives but
when the aunt gets stabbed like you
think well obviously Alice had reason to
stab her because she was like a [ __ ] on
wheels
and she hated that little girl but like
I said it was just that's what I really
like about this movie it's like it's
kind of like a nasty yeah movie because
they're putting all this on a
twelve-year-old yeah she wasn't the
murderer she didn't end up being the
murderer but yeah [ __ ] she was still up
to some like this question of I didn't
know they had a blu-ray release of this
I have actually really recent yeah now
that you said that I'm actually kind of
thinking about maybe buying that because
this is a good movie to have in your
catalog it does have this certain
Gestalt to it yeah vibe
it feels very kind of illicit in a
certain way yeah like a lot of movies
from that area yeah
you have interior shots of these um how
these apartment buildings that almost
kind of have a Victorian look to them
yeah and you could tell that it's like
really old-school lead-based paint it's
real [ __ ] yeah nasty paint on all the
[ __ ] door jams and [ __ ] you know I
mean and it just looks creepy and scuzzy
oh yeah whole [ __ ] movie does well
that's the way things were you know
knows yeah living in Detroit you know I
was in some of these old buildings from
that era and yeah that's the way they
were there was something kind of eerie
about all those old buildings like the
[ __ ] ceiling tiles and look like [ __ ]
you don't I mean yeah tacky patterns and
crap you know I mean and they just kind
of had a tomb like feel to everything
well and a lot of people have commented
on that now what's interesting is that
Alfred Sol the director before he
started making movies he was actually an
architect like and he worked on like
restorations and a lot of the buildings
that they shot in in Paterson New Jersey
he had worked on like doing restorations
so he actually got access to a lot of
these buildings that he maybe wouldn't
have otherwise yeah because this movie I
mean this seemed like a passion project
for him he basically remortgaged his
house he cleaned out his savings account
he wrote it with he wrote the screenplay
with his neighbor who was like an
English professor or something like that
named rosemary writ foe unfortunately I
don't think she ever wrote anything ever
again like other than maybe some cup of
scholarly text books or something but um
you know they got to talking they were
both like lapsed Catholics and I feel
like Alfred's soul particularly after
all of the [ __ ] that he had to go
through with his porno movie was kind of
like he also got excommunicated from the
Catholic Church when he did the porno
movie so he was like not a fan anymore
and so a lot of I feel like this movie
had kind of like particularly in Ireland
was you know a very Catholic country at
the time they had a big problem with it
because they thought it was very
anti-catholic which it kind of is
because is it well there's a couple
characters that are sympathetic like you
know like the young priest is
sympathetic and everything but the way
they portray Catholicism it's almost
kind of like I don't know I don't know
if I'd call it anti-catholic I don't but
it is kind of like use Catholicism as a
way of light of well that was the
backdrop that was yeah of this family
it's a it's an italian-american vampire
yeah community and they're gonna be
Catholic you know I don't have anything
against religion yeah I like religions
you know as long as they're taken for
what they are I look at the movie and I
don't see any disrespect I just see you
know yeah a backdrop that that's who
that community was and this [ __ ]
happened
they just didn't like the story I guess
it's because the killer ended up being
that super Catholic because she ended up
her whole motivation but that's
realistic yeah that were realist her
whole motivation was that
well she was mad because the little girl
the Brooke Shields character was being
given communion even though her parents
were divorced even though the earth the
older daughter had been denied communion
so she liked the lady that was the
killer she kind of had taken it upon
herself to punish like yeah people she
thought were sinners she thought she was
doing yeah what the church wanted III
understand I understand that I'm looking
at it from that point of view I kind of
disagree with them though I think that
it was it had a Catholic motif I thought
was very cool very effective to have
that look in that background very
realistic yeah you know but I don't
think it was anything against a
Catholicism you just had a psycho yeah
you know I mean in a Catholic background
that but that that's like that it was
kind of like because they didn't have
some like the people that my father Tom
yeah a young priest the begin he was
like a he was a guy and she carried her
you know I mean yeah yeah the old lady
killed him so it was not an anti
religion movie if you ask me
yeah I don't think it was and the thing
is you have to think too that there's
been a really lot of horror movies that
are focused around Catholicism I mean
how can you not like with all those like
cathedrals and candles Catholics
understand style right exactly it's just
creepy all of their [ __ ] is creepy
yeah I was drinking cannibalism all of
it you're gonna be religious be a
Catholic it's very [ __ ] goth [ __ ]
god it's religion I like it yeah no I
mean it's creepy yeah it is but it also
has its own you know what I mean
grandeur to it yeah very you know I like
it's very grandiose I like the style
well like I said you can see why so many
horror movies have been made like
centered around Catholicism around the
Catholic Church mean even like The
Exorcist and Steffan stigmata and [ __ ]
like that Baba's gonna go to church I'd
go to a Catholic Church because look
it's like a music in the visual
well yeah come on you don't even have to
like set dress che no just go in your
local Catholic you know Cathedral and
[ __ ] and you just fell them in there and
it's like it already there's your horror
movie it's in the can yeah
but yeah I'm just saying that like at
the time like honestly it seemed like it
got really good reviews at the time but
a couple people were kind of like a it
seems anti-catholic or whatever but I
don't know I didn't really get that I
didn't grow up Catholic so I wouldn't
really know her and I wouldn't be
offended anyway but um yeah and and the
thing is well well I think that was a
thing too about backward pray they
didn't like any kind of [ __ ] you know
I'm talking about they didn't like any
anything I know I know what they're
talking about that that's a that's a
very old-school critique of this movie
well yeah they thought everything was an
attack on religion back in those days
but by today's standards
that's not anti-catholic no you know
like I said if you were watching it
today I don't think that would even
occur to ya her to me no because I mean
I you know like I said I could see how
because I because I think that a lot of
Alice's jealousy stemmed from the fact
that she was denied Communion because
her parents were divorced because that
was kind of like a big deal I mean like
I said even though this came out in 1976
you have to imagine it was set in 1961
and the director said it in 1961 because
he wanted it that was when he grew up
and that was how retro in the day so he
that was how he remembered it he's like
I wanted it to be like my childhood was
because he was also raised in the
Catholic Church and in a very like
close-knit working-class Catholic
community so he was like I wanted it to
be like I remembered it so that's why he
said it back in 1961 even though if
you're watching it now like I said when
I watched it I don't even realize that
it was supposed to be earlier than that
it's it didn't really I felt something
was wrong with the cars and the way the
certainty yeah it looked and like they
didn't have any you know there was no
mention of 70 stuff yeah and then I
noticed in the background the calendar
was set on 1961 yeah and I pointed it I
was just look I was like it's a period
piece yeah then it started to fall into
place but that's why because that's when
he was a kid right yeah so he wanted it
to be like it's a good movie it's good
it is there like I said there's a lot of
in it and it's one that you really need
to see it's kind of like don't look now
in the sense that you need to see it a
bunch of times because there was a but
there's a bunch of [ __ ] like going on in
this that I don't think is really
obvious on the first go-around yeah it's
like there's a lot of parallels between
the relationship between the two sisters
and the relationship between the mom and
the aunt there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] about like blood
about the communion about the girl
having her period and not telling your
mom there's like all this kind of stuff
that's going on but like I said it's
it's like a slasher in the sense that
it's pretty violent for the time like a
lot of the stabbings are pretty are
giallo esque yeah um you know you get to
see like a knife going to a foot it's
like a jested that it's violent yeah
it's a creepy I don't think I think a
lot of it was suggested yeah a lot of it
was there was a lot of blood in it you
didn't but she didn't actually see
exactly what had happened yeah yeah well
in the barn the barn scene or she was
gonna fall time when she tied him up and
was gay oh and she's and she lays B
smashes face like his house is pretty
nasty yeah so it does have like some
nasty kind of [ __ ] in it
but as I said I would call this a
slasher but not not in the front not in
the Friday 13th kind of sense yeah this
is more like it's a lot slower than that
yeah and it's there it plays a lot more
with like the psychological world like
the family drama like the horror between
like the characters and I see these
reviews of like some of these younger
people they'll sit eating Conan the
Barbarian oh it was slow you know I mean
and I think it's because ladies young
kids they don't understand philosophy
and they don't understand the meaning of
certain things they want everything to
be like a video game word just happens
but come one second after another they
don't really understand the ambience and
the tone of a movie some stories have to
be told Conesus
lowly and this is one of those stories
yeah it unfolds at a certain speed you
have to [ __ ] watch what's happening
and kind of immerse yourself in that
world because in the 70s films were
supposed to be kind of realistic yeah if
we watch a movies today we go to the
theater all-time on a list the movies
that we see today are fast paced but
they're not realistic that's not the way
life unfolds yes unfolded that speed and
that changed happened really I think in
the 80s it did yet and I think a lot of
the younger people of today it's not
like a little [ __ ] Mandana I can't
understand it
grandpa a lot of the younger maybe a lot
of younger people a day are actually
used to stories unfolding a lot faster
yeah they don't [ __ ] enjoy the ride
the way we did well and I think horror
movies in particular you know and I
don't want to make like a categorical
statement because sometimes you can just
have like a long pretentious slog that
doesn't need to be as long as it is as
it is but I think horror in particulars
of genre I think that it benefits from
having room to breathe yeah it's kind of
having to build up an atmosphere and
build up so that you care about the
characters actually um you know because
it makes the horror more impactful I
feel like if you just have people
getting slashed you know one after the
other one or the other it's like nobody
gives a [ __ ] that gets boring yes you're
making it an action movie and you don't
give a [ __ ] about the writebol so it's
like it doesn't have any impact right
that's why I kind of like movies I mean
like I said I've you know I like gory
movies as much as anybody but in some
ways I like movies that take the time
right to build up the situation to build
up the character so that when someone
gets murdered you're like oh [ __ ] oh no
you know what I mean right and this one
does that I mean even the the evil
landlord fat would I call him our nose
like the inside of a trying to think of
another word for fat that would fit her
to that they actually give you time to
get to to get to
no phantom lavae and in an action movie
wouldn't be that way but phantom look
baby get look at 20 seconds of screen
time that was it so you know I just
liked the way they did seventies or yeah
you know I liked it and like you said
this is structured I mean if you're into
Italian jolly movies it's true you
should be go get on this portable hero
love this [ __ ] yeah it's here now I'm
not gonna say because giallo movies I
mean yeah they get a lot of flack for
like being incoherent like the plots a
coherent stuff but I've seen a lot of
them yeah and some of them make a lot
more sense than others some of them are
just like straight-up murder mysteries
yeah and you know are pretty
straightforward I think Dario Argento um
you know his movies kind of like got
into that because he was very into like
the dreamlike imagery and everything
like that but I think if you watch his
movies more than once they mostly kind
of makes sense I would put this update
up there with almost kind of like the
tenant yeah some people like I saw some
comments on our review the tenant or
people watched it you know it was a
younger guy he's like now I wasted all
my time watching that movie the tenant
the tenant was [ __ ] awesome it was a
slow-burning movie and it was a movie
about a bullfight when you got done with
that movie you're like that was weird
but what what was that about what
actually yeah like I said I always liked
movies that I didn't like I need to
watch it again like you want to watch it
again
lifts you very a lien ate it at the end
you're like what happened was I just
leave weird after there was that was
that possessed or whatever and I love
that I keep looking for that in horror
movies it's like I want a horror movie
that makes me feel like super weird
yeah and in case you guys don't know
that go what go see our review of the
tenant that tenant was a Roman Polanski
movie and you know a lot of people talk
[ __ ] about Roman because what what
happened yeah was another era
I made some kick ass no business he his
movie that particular movie there the
tenant was a masterpiece we need to do
repulsion tale yeah
one of these days Lansky is I [ __ ]
love repulsion Polanski knew how to make
it an old-school movie well he knew how
to like unsettle you yeah the problem I
think and I I don't think
I've seen like you know you it's I don't
think it's just a problem of the younger
generation I because a lot of horror
channels that I watch on YouTube a lot
of them are younger people like in their
20s or 30s and they're into the same
memories that I've been to so I I think
it's more a personality type because
I've seen like some older people type to
you that are just like I think some
people just have like maybe impatience
and I think - there's a thing it's
particularly in the horror genre and I
[ __ ] hate this I hate people that you
know they'll watch all this [ __ ] is like
own doesn't scares me it's like it's not
scary it's not this then the other thing
and I think the problem is that they
won't let themselves get immersed in the
movie they won't like let themselves
feel the emotions that the so I always
get like pissed off at these like but
I'm sure they're probably like 13 years
old or something like that like all
these [ __ ] edge lords coming out
doing oh I watched a Serbian film and I
just laughed through the whole thing I'm
just like whatever so it's like so I
hate that kind of person if you're going
to watch horror and appreciate horror I
mean I'm you know I'm not gonna shoot it
so like you like what you like or
whatever but if you're going to watch a
horror movie
let yourself surrender to the movie get
into the movie let yourself like feel
the emotions that are put forth by the
movie and then see how you feel about it
don't like spend the whole time being
all detached and like you're too cool to
be scared by it are you too cool for
this and that it's like that's not I
just feel like that's not gonna be
effective you're not really gonna enjoy
anything like that you know what I mean
if you talk about the tenant and
Polanski that was almost a Kubrick in
horror movie it was yeah yeah it was
very detailed very very odd I tell you
what that [ __ ] you unsettling see this
is something that always bothers me in
movies and the tenant did it David Lynch
does it a lot and it I don't know why
but it freaks me the [ __ ] out I hate it
what I don't hate it I love it actually
but it like freaks me out when somebody
like looks and they see their
doppelganger yeah oh that freaks me that
happened in the 10
the tenant like when he looks out the
window and that he looks in the bathroom
and that freaks me the [ __ ] out it finds
a tooth inside the wall and like see to
me like suggestion is airier yeah you
know what I mean so I I feel like these
are just us because Skinny Puppy [ __ ]
quoted the tenant over and over again
and all those songs about you know well
I'm like I said I've seen so many like
take off my head what do I see
I see me in my head or me in my body
yeah what right does my head have to
call itself me that's some weird [ __ ]
yeah what the right Dee's your head have
to call itself you yeah why are you so
head centric but yeah I just for me it's
like suggestion and like I said I'm not
[ __ ] on Gore movies I [ __ ] love
Gore movies you can just do all the
bloody like intestines it should all day
long I love that [ __ ]
but if a movie is going to like scare me
disturb me like give me nightmares and
stuff like that it's gonna be suggestion
yeah like I said the cool thing about
the tenant is he finds a [ __ ] tooth
in a hole in the wall and you're just
like your imagination starts going like
how the [ __ ] did that get in there well
then what was the situation behind ami a
tooth missing yeah and it's like so I
love that kind of [ __ ] and so I think
that that's why movies like Alice sweet
Alice movies like you know don't look
now which this is very which Alice we
doll is very much resembles um a lot of
it is built on suggestion a lot of it is
built on this kind of character dynamic
like family drama and [ __ ] like that
because don't look now had that as well
like with the grief over the death of
their daughter and stuff and this kind
of has a similar vibe this kind of like
horribly dysfunctional family and you
know all these kind of like oppressive
forces like outside of them like [ __ ]
everything up nobody has a healthy
relationship with one another and it's
just like adds to like the terror like
you know they're blaming this poor
little twelve-year-old girl and then the
the fact of them doing that yeah seems
like it's leading her down a path that
may be they don't water to go down so I
really like that they played with that
you know he wasn't afraid to like play
with that kind of [ __ ] I mean like I
said
even though the actress was 19 years old
when she was in the movie but she's
supposed to be a 12 year old kid she
looks she looks like a 12 year old kid I
would never have known but the fact that
he had the balls to like put this 12
year old in the center of this fucked-up
situation the fucked-up family - dynamic
like a [ __ ] serial killer situation
also I mean I don't know if you I was
gonna say I don't know if he could go
get away with that now but I think you
probably could I would put this movie
more more along the lines of the other
it's like an Italian American version of
the other yeah if you like that movie
you'd like this one yeah I definitely
like I said and if you like don't look
now you love this this it has kind of a
black Christmassy kind of vibe to it -
and if you like Italian jo movies from
the 70s they like then you should check
this out because if you right up your
alley like I said check it out it's on
to be for free at this time when we're
filming it which is whatever the hell
day it is yeah may not be there but
it'll be on YouTube
I checked it earlier today which is
September 1st yeah today's September 1st
we're filming this and it was on there a
couple hours ago probably so go check it
out they're probably on YouTube yeah and
it is on YouTube if you don't mind
watching it like shitty VHS : yeah so go
check it out we will see you next time
bye